diamanten geschmeide perlen das was
kriminelle aus sachsens schatzkammer dem
grünen gewölbe gestohlen haben ist in
seinem wert nicht nur unbezahlbar
es ist krisenfest sachwerte seien das
einzige was einen finanzcrash überstehen
würde sagt unser gast marc friedrich und
der crash der kommt friedrich legt sich
fest spätestens 2023 ist es soweit
börsencrash hyperinflation der
zusammenbruch des euro die finanzkrise
2008 sei dagegen nicht mehr als eine
leichte brise gewesen wir sagen den
sparerinnen und sparern dass ihre
einlagen sicher sind auch dafür steht
die bundesregierung ein ein solches
versprechen sich dann wohl nicht mehr
wohin also mit dem ersparten der rat von
marc friedrich oldtimer steigen im kurs
kunstwerke ebenfalls land geht immer
feld wald und whisky das gute zeug
versteht sich flüssig bleiben garantiert
streuobstwiesen
das ist ja gold bitcoin alles um so mehr
geld die notenbank druckt umso mehr
braucht man gegengewicht eine art
lebensversicherung gegen diesen wahnsinn
weil noch nie wurde die krise durch
gelddrucken gelöst und noch nie wurde
wohlstand durch gelddrucken genau das
haben wir den 20er jahren in deutschland
versucht macht uns doch irgendwie seit
den 70er jahren
wir haben die meldung aber du bist jetzt
ab wer eines der reichsten länder der
welt sein aber wir haben 100 trillionen
dollar scheinen also man kann nicht
wohlstand erzeugen durch gelddrucken und
die notenbank wird als nächstes nicht
nur die zinsen in den negativbereich
senken nein die wird auch noch aktien
kaufen mit dem aufkauf programmen und
die werden auch noch helikopter geld
verteilen das heißt sie werden alle noch
hier geld bekommen bekommen 510.000 euro
also wir sind im endspiel monetären
endspiel wir sehen einfach eine
verzweifelte notenbanken werden auch nie
wieder steigende zinsen im euro system
erleben
im gegenteil die zinsen werden
negativbereich abrauschen und das was
nicht funktioniert sehen wir ja anhand
dessen dass die notenbank jetzt schon
auf kraft programm gestartet hat mit 20
milliarden euro im monat wo weitere
zombie unternehmen künstlich am leben
erhalten bleiben
die bank of international zettel man die
notenbank der notenbank geht davon aus
dass in der eurozone 15
alle unternehmen zombie unternehmen sind
das heißt gibt es nur noch weil die
zinsen so niedrig sind und weil die mit
billigem geld künstlich am leben
erhalten sekunden nur dass sie es
versteht auf diese 2023 sommercrash
spätestens und woher haben sie diese
gewissheit also warum spätestens in vier
jahren
das sind so viele indikatoren erstens
die südlichen länder europas müssen sich
in den nächsten jahren mit hunderten
milliarden an staatsanleihen
refinanzieren da ist die frage wer kauft
die noch außer der ezb ja parallel haben
wir jetzt schon die banken und die
versicherung die werte gibt es ein
großes banken versicherungs sterben weil
der nullzins unter negativzins die
bilanzen und die gewinne von den im euro
raum auffrisst wir sehen die aktienkurse
deutsche bank commerzbank den müssen
verstaatlicht werden weil spätestens in
zwei jahren werden die umkippen müssen
dann muss der staat eingreifen dürfen
wieder garantien vergeben weil die
einfach nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind
also ein großes banken versicherungs
sterben wird kommen dann haben wir die
ganzen probleme mit den negativzinsen
wir haben 2,6 billionen euro durch die
aufkaufprogramme der ezb ins system
gepumpt für die wir alle haften also die
risiken steigen vor allem die deutschen
weil wir haben den größten anteil über
die bundesbank an der ezb also in so
viele indikatoren parallel werden die
ganzen hierfür sprechen aus ihrer sicht
ich gebe mir ganz kurz weiter anhalten
fratzscher also zusammenbruch vor allen
dingen ausgelöst im euroraum ist da für
sie irgendetwas nachvollziehbar an der
argumente
na gut sie waren immer bei der ezb
beschäftigt sie könne nichts anderes
sagen ich bin ich bin zwar ökonom ist
vielmehr die krisen angeschaut hätte ich
auch eigentlich es gibt eigentlich
überhaupt kein wissenschaftlicher basis
für ihre argumente wenn sie sich das
bankensystem und finanzsystem anschauen
dann haben viele banken eigenkapital
aufgebaut die konsolidierung das
bankensterben was sie bescheiden ist
etwas gesundes und notwendiges dass die
konsolidierung von finanzinstitutionen
gibt das macht die finanzinstitutionen
stärker die große chance als erster
deutscher banken 90 liquiditätsschwemme
sie haben keine keine grundlage dafür
schauen sich die landgemeinden hoch
dennoch ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich
als wissenschaft bezeichnen kann ich
glaube es nicht
der bundeswehr angegeben demagogie da
hat nichts mit fakten zu tun das ist
einfach nur schwarzmalerei
tatsache ist der reale europäische
länder haben harte reform gemacht
schauen sich spanien an
schauen sie sich portugal anschauen sich
irland an diesen auf einem guten weg das
finanzsystem ist am gesunden und die
liquidität der forscher noch mal dass
tatsächlich wahnsinnig viele unternehmen
stichwort zombie unternehmen nur am
leben erhalten werden weil es so viel
billiges geld gibt und die wären längst
in konkurs men ist das nicht gäbe
auch das ist eigentlich falsch denn
natürlich bedeutet niedrige zinsen
bedeuten erst einmal dass alle
unternehmen sich günstiger finanzieren
können
und natürlich gibt es immer unternehmen
gegen die konkurrenz unternehmen könnte
es übernehmen und auch die wir jetzt
start up unternehmens junge unternehmen
die neue ideen haben die haben eine
chance in sollen die umfeld zu wachsen
da hingehen weil sich das ticket bei den
schlechten unternehmen eine war die
vision wird gestoppt
da ist überhaupt keine grundlage
überhaupt keine grundlage
wenn es wirklich dem schreiben der mann
ist gerade auch in deutschland stehen
fertigungsanlagen und klar wir haben
herausforderungen aber wir sind weit
gekommen und diese diese demagogie es
gibt kein geld ich weiß nicht manches zu
wollen scheint klar sie machen werbung
für die bundesbank
also was wir erleben seit 2008 ist ein
historischer vertrauensverlust in das
geldsystem in die banken bei dem alle
betrogen haben in die politik weil die
die wird demokratisch legitimiert haben
nicht uns vertreten haben in der krise
sondern den banken zur seite gesprungen
sind und auch mit unseren steuergeldern
gerettet haben und garantien gegeben
haben lara den haben wir noch einen
natürlichen klang wir alle haben doch
für den ganzen kladderadatsch für die
griechenland rettung
diese sind in die tage zwei seiten auf
ihre cockney wo wir keine krise haben
wissen sie haben 2012 jahren der
griechen nannten euro gelegen haben
recht bei der frage kann die ezb immer
weiter anleiheaufkaufprogramm machen
vergemeinschaftung der schulden ist
nicht unser weg verteilen das nicht was
da passiert und brüssel kann man
kritisch sind
sie dürfen auch nicht weglassen wichtig
verantwortung in europa zu mindestens
auch umfasst das wir auch die
südeuropäischen staaten nicht einfach
ihrem schicksal alleine überlassen
konnten aber es macht doch keinen sinn
wenn griechenland sich momentan
günstiger verschulden kann an den
kapitalmärkten die die usa wir wissen
doch alle diese de facto bankrott
italien genauso diese nun regiert haben
staatsverschuldung gehört eine und als
bruder und trotzdem können sie sich so
günstig verschulden wie noch nie in der
geschichte
aber das ist das szenario und 2023
bricht alles zusammen 324 leben zu
ertrinken und das schicksal zu ertragen
das ist auch keine lösung und was sinn
macht ist dass die die verantwortung
tragen immer auch lösungen bringen
müssen und das regelt sie aber nicht die
politik versagt auf ganzer linie
wir erleben doch nicht überall so
schauen sie doch die wahlen in leerem
und mangan liegen die die rechten und
die linken haben da erstmalig die die
mehrheit bekommen und wir werden
weiterhin tendenzen sind dass die ränder
immer stärker werden weil die menschen
das vertrauen in die etablierten
parteien verlieren und es lade völlig zu
recht weiter tragisch sind und weil sie
inkompetent sind also denken
andere ist also ich sehe auch ich finde
man kann sich auch nicht so einfach
machen diese probleme die sie
angesprochen haben einfach wegzuwischen
es gibt unglaubliche ungleichgewichte in
der euro-zone es gibt einen riesigen
schulden überhang den gibt es die dem
wissen sie auch herr frhr
also ich meine italien beispielsweise
und andere länder sind natürlich seit
jahren nicht wieder auf die beine
gekommen also das toreschießen ist ganz
niedrig na ob sie es nicht werden hängt
natürlich von der politik aber solange
ist in der gesamten eurozone im grunde
nur eine ideologie gibt man darf auf gar
keinen fall irgendwie kreditfinanzierte
investitionsprogramm auflegen und die
staaten das befolgen so lange wird es
auch nicht funktionieren
die horde sein hat es zum beispiel nicht
befolge die haben tatsächlich die hatten
das land auch nicht mit leder aber dass
sie erst brauchen mich nicht also wenn
die politik so weitermacht wie bisher
und wenn sie immer noch an den falschen
ideologien falschen modellen und
falschen interessen festhält und wenn
sie es tatsächlich auch jetzt wieder wo
sich die jetzt drückt sicher die
wirtschaftslage gerade wieder ein
und wenn sie immer noch nicht begreift
dass sie tatsächlich eine politik für
die mehrheit der leute machen muss und
nicht für banken nicht für große
unternehmen nicht das was die lobby ist
neben erzählen wenn das alles so weiter
geht wie bisher dann ist die gefahr groß
ich finde es ein bisschen fahrlässig das
so mit einem wohligen schauer zu
erzählen und sozusagen als ging es gar
nicht anders weil ich möchte mir nicht
vorstellen welche politischen
konsequenzen ein solcher finanzcrash
hätte da haben sie nämlich tatsächlich
recht wir wissen wie das nach den 20er
30er jahren ausgegangen ist und deswegen
brauchen wir eine andere politik damit
ist genau zu diesem horror szenarien